and for wascory noah tommy build on what
he did last time out i guess yeah short
memory about what happened in chicago
two starts to go focus more on what
happened versus arizona six innings of
two hit two run ball with five
strikeouts
threw the ball well look for him to go
out there tonight and have a better much
better outing than he did against the
cubbies the last time look at the top of
the order you think anthony rizzo top of
the order well he's done it a lot
actually
and he just showed it off there was that
tip nope rizzo missed it cleanly andy
noah does have his first strikeout and
duffy coaxes a walk and chris bryant
will come up here in the first inning oh
two goodbye swung on and missed got him
with a slider and juan scary noah
bookends the top of the first with
strikeouts no runs no hits no errors in
one lap kyle hendricks
the last time he faced these braves it
was a very difficult night for kyle
he allowed four home runs in the very
first inning that was on the sunday
night game april 18 at wrigley
and kyle went on to lose that ball game
so he'll obviously hope to fare much
better tonight
freddie freeman two for seven in the
series including a single last night and
a bases loaded walk so one pitch on the
way that's served out to left field and
freddie's one for one a one ounce single
out of freddy freeman is third base end
of the series and the braves have their
first base runner of the ball game that
brings marcelo zuna up to the plate two
for ten in the series but he's had some
loud outs to this point
high fly ball off speed he crushed that
baby marcelo zuna has put the braves in
front
yeah take a selfie marcel and the grand
tour
well right on cue chip you talked about
the struggles with the breaking ball you
talked about the extra work they've been
putting in
and it pays off he got a hanging
breaking ball hendricks knew it as soon
as he let go of it
marcel didn't
last night he was two for four with a
pair of doubles his third multi-hit game
of the season three two pitch that's
cracked down the right field line and a
base hit this rolls into the corner all
the way to the wall how about another
two bagger out of ozzie with more
doubles and a happy hour
well i wouldn't go that far
it has been a struggle
and it is so far tonight there's another
shot this one off riley's bat bryant's
gonna turn that ball's in the bullpen
another home run
it's bombs away in atlanta ga it's four
to nothing
he had a really good first inning couple
of strikeouts
and the bats gave him four runs on the
bottom of the first inning now he faces
hayward boaty and mariznick
and hayward's down on strikes that's the
third of the game
and one man down as david bodie the
hitter a ball and two strikes
seven at bats three
strikeouts and add another to the ledger
four strikeouts for wascarino
and was coming to the plate don't sleep
on this kid picked up his first big
league hits in an rbi to boot
and he rips one to right better hustle
the first because hayward will throw it
there he noah has another hit takes it
the other way looks to the dugout and
says guys it's not that hard
back-to-back singles for the braves out
of inoha and acuna and here comes
freddie
golfed into right center field
mauriznick won't get there that's down
for a base hit you know around thirds
gonna get the green light the cubs miss
the cutoff man and acuna is coming
not in home
aconia scores from first on a ball to a
shallow right center field gap first the
stumble that's why they missed the
cutoff man and as the ball trickled away
from bodhi and ronald turned on the
afterburners he was green lighted he
didn't run through a stop sign
and he slid in ahead of the tag and the
braves have scored six in the first two
innings
dubs have a man on for wilson contreras
on the ground riley's got it bad hop
stayed with it ozzy and a turn and
not in time a little loop of a throw
from ozzy obese
as rizzo came in at the second base bag
clean play and contreras hustling down
the line in a six-nothing game keeps the
ending alive for the single out of duffy
runners at first and third and still two
down and brings chris brown to the plate
two under the plate
chopper out to third charging is riley
gloves it bobbles now throws bang bang
play that's in time
freddy had to dig it out of the dirt got
out his shovel pulled it right out of
the sand
and that ends the top of the third
inning
meanwhile he noah has kept the cub match
quiet five strikeouts he's giving him
three hits
he did and hayward didn't get it he is
now over 24 on non-fastballs this year
and he's struck out twice that is number
six in the game for huascari noah body
took a little time to get back in the
box took a little punishment after that
last foul ball the next one on the way
and a swing and a miss
back-to-back strikeouts that's 7-40 noah
32 strikeouts on the year
tipped and caught he just struck out the
side
you know has eight strikeouts on the
night i think everybody in the national
league was worried how would the
pitchers hit after not doing it since
2019 well they're making a strong case
for not having the dh
high fly ball did he did he
noah has hit a homer
waskari noah his first home run
he rounds third base taking his time and
don't you know they're partying in the
dominican
it'll be nothing like the party in the
dugout coming up see if he gets the
silent treatment here yeah he's getting
it there there they come
as heredia digs in the braves
battle on here in the seventh in a seven
nothing game the 1-1
hit hard down the third base line
fairball past duffy bryant getting to it
but not in time to keep riley from
scoring and now bryant kicks it horady
is at second he'll hold there with an
rbi double
eight to nothing brave
and yeah that's to be the last hitter
for wascarinoa through 101 pitches
and he should get a big ovation from
this crowd in atlanta
wascarinoa had a little league game
pitching a shot out he hit a home run
listen to truest park say thank you
wascarinor
and freddie freeman
is leading off the inning
hangar and a high fly ball deep right
field it's a perfect night for freeman
all he needs is the triple
who's four for four and the braves are
leading nine nothing ozzie's two for
three he's doubled
scored a run
weights
and swings and he sends a drive to right
field that one's deep ian happ at the
padding at the wall gone home run ozzy
albies
puts the braves in double digits it's 10
to nothing
and if you are a fan of position players
pitching well
this is your game because look who is on
the mound for the chicago cubs
so now here's the county
throw me the fastball
yeah he's trying saying i will but it's
not going to be what you're used to
as acuna takes ball for
freeman versus rizzo look at him he can
pick if he can't even look at him yeah
he's thinking i need a triple for the
cycle and i can't contain my laughter
right now how am i going to hit
oh he struck him out
look at risso he can't believe it
anthony rizzo just struck out freddie
freeman
with a breaking ball
look at freddie's reaction
that is great
three balls two strikes
in the air to left ozuna retreats he's
got it and that's the winner the braves
beat the cubs again ten to nothing